hello and welcome to the shaking silence
shape we're in this video we're going to
talk about Google's secret silence TV
and big rafael we're going to be talking
about calculate which is one of Google's
many any baby companies and calico is
one that it's a little bit mysterious in
terms of what it's actually doing so
let's just jump straight in so calico
the name actually comes from the
California life company it's not named
after cupcake at all though the company
like to say the old saying that cats do
have nine lives
but anyway if we go into that websites
the main thing they say is what's
happening aging one of life's greatest
mysteries so it seems the main aim of
this company is to understand lifespan
and its regulation and on their front
page they have this picture of a tree
trunk and I'm assuming the link between
that is somewhat due to the fact that
this tree clearly lived a long time and
also if we go back to the logo you'll
notice that the color code sees actually
kind of mimic the structure of the tree
trunk crew so what do we actually know
about kalki well we know that it's come
from people and it's their whole
furniture focused on understanding aging
and so this is why I make a Jake in my
title about it not being me as their
baby because I talk about aging a lot on
this channel apparently and so the
company is also I guess somewhat baby
because it was only founded in 2013 and
it now actually comes underneath the
alphabet Inc of the Goo Goo corporation
honestly I don't really stands how that
company structure is a little bit
complicated and they have about 1.5
billion apparently don't trust that
number you're working for but it's a
good company and they probably have a
lot of investment should they need it to
be able to uncover agen but if you get
back to their website there really isn't
much information regarding anything
specific about what they're studying so
this needs the question what I think
actually doing so I guess somewhat
ironically now I looked into Google
search for some answer
and I came across this article when it
seemed a bit uncertain and this article
about Google is super secretive about
his anti-aging research no one knows why
and so this article is when I could
actually access and also to quite
interesting because they had quotes from
different scientists and so they asked
Eric table who I speaking about one of
his books before and he has colleagues
who have joined kérékou and says that
hyper secretive I have invited them to
speak at our program we have on genomic
medicine they say no they can't talk
about what they're doing so I thought
that was a little bit mysterious and I
do like a good mystery so I went back to
calculate site to see what I really
could find out about it it might
detective skills to test I'm wondering
about looking you is they have a lot of
collaborations with different
universities and other companies and if
you want to partner with Kyle okay
obviously they need to release some bit
of information about what they do as a
company but again it's all just a little
bit fake in terms of the actual areas of
interest because they say that they're
exploring the genetics of aging and
human populations and focusing on the
hallmarks of aging which we all know I
know a little bit about so that includes
producers stressful sponsors cellular
senescence and to do this they're using
a variety of different model organisms
from East worms to make it more rods and
also studying neuro degeneration chronic
inflammation and metabolic dysfunction
and I'm cancer as well and that all
comes underneath the big branch of Aging
so again it's just a little bit big and
then if you try to find out who that
actually collaborating with it kind of
just takes you further down their
webpage we didn't really were faulty
much but I have done a bit of research
and say they collaborate with AB fee the
braid Institute and also with the
University of Pennsylvania and that's
just the name of you but I thought we
could also learn something from looking
at fees and fault of the company so as I
was looking through their team members I
recognised Cynthia Kenyon he was pretty
you know big name in the understanding
the genetics of Aging and so she's the
vice president of the aging research
part of calico
so I mean that's pretty from the same I
mean I can only assume that she's doing
it's not I'm saying yeah I want a
committal of a fake it doesn't really
say too much but I thought we could also
learn something about the different jobs
that they have to offer and what fast
lien--a says they have quite a few
postings with job positions and one that
caught my eye was one about cellular
senescence and cancer biology which is
pretty much my PhD and a nutshell and
this project focuses on the naked mole
rat so again it talks about the types of
model organisms that this company is
fixing on and yeah I mean they're always
gonna be a bit fake with job sessions I
suppose but yeah everything just seems a
little bit fake and say I think that's
what these articles are coming from that
you know it's calico it's funded by
Google it's promising some think about
aging research and I mean there are some
publications that you could look at but
again it you know with those
collaborations nothing seems very
specific to calico itself so what is it
that they're doing is that something
really big that they just didn't want to
reveal at the moment and it's one of
those if I tell you I have to kill you
scenarios who knows but I did find
equate from David Botstein the chief
scientific officer of calico and one of
the first reports when Kalki first
started he said that the best case
scenario is that calico will have
something profound to offer the world in
10 years so you know maybe it's just a
matter of waiting and see what that
something is
so hopefully this has covered a bit well
probably hasn't really uncovered any bit
of the mystery to do with calico but oh
well hopefully you've learned something
nonetheless and as always thanks for
listening